Deadpool last week you had a pretty
advanced case of being charming
self-aware a depressingly fitting
spokesman for 7-eleven an alcoholic soft
dream breaking the fourth wall it's
getting really bad the first draft of
Deadpool 3 is 6 hours long this is how I
remind you what I really am Nickelback
2001 deposed your Underwood any falling
off the wagon this week
no no no the state of the union is
strong
Chloe means well but her credentials are
underwhelming son of a [ __ ] I got a run
mr. robots she doesn't even know my name
can you blame her names are a [ __ ]
construe there's a fourth wall on the
ceiling there's a fifth wall Jim who can
you trust this therapist who's google
drive is nothing but suicide note drafts
and hence I do you trust the workplace
bully who will one day cause an autistic
beat farmer to move out of state no
trust no one
Society I had a nice week Chloe I don't
even know what hentai is so um Jim truth
is if you break the fourth wall long
enough eventually the fourth wall breaks
you promised to donate my brain for
research dibs on Pam
oh hello I know right this genre is
super exciting to me can absolute dream
honey I love working with Shawn
obviously I've worked with him stranger
things and he's just amazing
I'm really mostly here for taiko that
I've been a huge fan of his for a long
time and it's super cool to finally meet
him yeah yeah I mean do that for me as
well I've known about Ryan for a long
time and you know that we've covered
we've always been trying to like meet up
or connect or work together at somewhere
and to finally get that chance to
actually be in the same thing together
for the first time ever there's actually
more did you guys talking about I don't
think so not from my mother this is the
first time we've met best cool thing
about the industry it brings people
together
we've been mutual admirers of each other
for a long time from afar and now to
finally have a chance to work together
for the first time ever and both of our
lives is super stoked about that and be
in the same room Green Lantern yeah yeah
Green Lantern Tom you understand what we
could learn for Kent State pilot he wore
uniform I'm thinking is a soldier give
me this riposte I think so that you're
thinking of Jessica Tandy Kathy Bates
fried fried green tomatoes that I
remember you guys Seth Rogen Green
Hornet it's this that's where you'll get
in confusion amazing in that but neither
of us will see us right welcome back
everyone it's Charlie we have a Deadpool
three Robot Chicken trailer to break
down nice parody and Ryan Reynolds and
Ty Cobb itd making so much fun of Green
Lantern I always loved Ryan Reynolds
making fun of Green Lantern and his
other own movies there's a whole bunch
of Easter eggs will do an update on
what's going on with Deadpool 3 under
Marvel Studios now that all the Fox
character
at Marvel there's some changes made to
what the original plans for Deadpool 3
in the next couple of Deadpool movies
were going to be Fox did have a whole
big plan because Deadpool was their big
a-list characters so of course there
were gonna be a whole bunch of Deadpool
sequels Marvel isn't completely wiping
the slate clean but it's gonna be a
little bit different now that they're
with Disney we're doing a giveaway for
the new spider-man far from home blu-ray
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about spider-man crossing over with
Deadpool in the MCU now if you guys
don't remember a little while ago when
Spiderman got into trouble between
Marvel and Disney Ryan Reynolds himself
even started chiming in joking because
he's sort of in a holding pattern right
now they're gonna make Deadpool 3 but
they're not gonna make it right away so
he's free to make as many jokes about
Marvel and spider-man stuff that he
wants people ask him are you ever going
to be in a movie with spider-man but now
apparently largely thanks to Tom
Hollands efforts based on what
everyone's reporting spider-man back in
the MCU for another couple of movies
they'll obviously renegotiate for more
after that just making it way easier for
Deadpool to actually crossover with
spider-man in a legit MCU movie but in
the Deadpool trailer they have Deadpool
in fourth-wall rehab with a whole bunch
of other characters from pop culture
that break the fourth wall on their own
shows Jim Halpert from the office Kevin
Spacey's character Francis Underwood
from house of cards the ankle bracelet
is just a joke about all the legal
problems he's having in real life right
now
then Rami Malik's mr. robot character I
don't even know what hentai is they joke
about him trying to finish the Deadpool
3 script it's 6 hours long and in trying
to get that movie going at Disney just
making it sound like yeah obviously
Disney's gonna take their time getting
mutants into the MCU so that means it's
gonna take a little bit longer to get
Deadpool 3 they make another Nickelback
joke
nice double tap to the Nickelback jokes
during Once Upon a Deadpool
we are Marvel yeah you know Marvel
license by Fox it's like if the Beatles
were produced by Nickelback it's music
but it sucks then Ryan Reynolds and Tyco
YTD taking a whole bunch of rips on
Green Lantern so if you guys didn't
remember obviously everybody knows Ryan
Reynolds was in Green Lantern because
everybody always makes fun of Ryan
Reynolds Green Lantern but Tyga YTD was
also featured pretty heavily during that
movie a lot of people forget that he's
been an actor for a while now just that
he
blew up so big with thor ragnarok that
people have been thinking mostly about
that stuff yes he plays chord but that's
motion capture so you don't really see
his face like he was seated a lot of his
other big movies that he's done fun
facts side note too when there was talk
about crossing Deadpool over before the
Fox Disney deal Tyga even said that he'd
love to do a crossover movie with Thor
and Deadpool but big status update on
what's going on with Deadpool 3 at
Disney and Marvel Studios so there is
still a Deadpool 3 it's still happening
the Disney CEO and Kevin Feige have said
many times through this whole process
they're not gonna mess with Ryan
Reynolds version of the character he's
gonna be one of the few things to
survive intact the transition between
universes a little while ago when Kevin
Feige released his statement about them
signing the deal to bring spider-man
back into the MCU he talked about
spider-man being one of the few
characters that can jump between
cinematic universes referring to him
jumping between the venom versus Sony
because it'd be crossing over with those
movies in the MCU movies Deadpool is
also going to be one of those characters
so a lot of the x-men characters will
just be straight-up reboots and because
of the way the character is written and
his ability to be so meta and break the
fourth wall he's the way that you bring
all that pre-existing x-men Fox Canon
like Hugh Jackman Wolverine into the MCU
without actually having to have Hugh
Jackman himself on screen but a lot of
people point out the fact that Disney is
not gonna release a rated R movie under
the Disney label that's why Kevin Feige
will most likely wind up releasing
Deadpool 3 through Fox before the big
Fox Disney buyout the original plan
because Deadpool was such a big money
earner for them was to do a legit
Deadpool x-force movie next after
Deadpool - then do Deadpool 3 is a
completely separate movie Drew Goddard
who's the person responsible for
daredevil on Netflix he was originally
gonna do Sony's sinister six franchise
during the Andrew Garfield era he was
going to be Fox's architect of the
bigger Deadpool x-force team-up
franchise movies they were supposed to
be the r-rated hardcore versions of your
traditional x-men classic character team
ups in fact a lot of it would have felt
similar to the first part of Deadpool 2
where he actually assembles the team but
then you have to imagine that they
actually treat the team-up seriously
instead of killing off the whole team
after five minutes a year - after that
movie they would have released
Deadpool three and that would have been
him returning to a much smaller film
with the lower budget fewer characters
and that's probably what the new Marvel
Studios Deadpool three will be like the
Joker movie very small exists in its own
little bubble outside the regular DC
movie continuity Justice League Wonder
Woman 1984 Deadpool solo movies are
going to be a little bit like that where
they're kind of connected to the MCU
it'll enable them to do it rated R
release it through Fox and then when
they want to actually have Deadpool
interacting with the other big Avengers
characters in Avengers 5 that'll be
pg-13 Deadpool and there just be
references to the timeline to give it a
loose continuity between the Deadpool
solo films and the Deadpool MCU films
that's actually kind of the way that
Sony and Marvel are gonna handle
spider-man jumping between the venom
movies and the MCU movies without
necessarily having to canonize
everything in terms of actual release
date just look at the Marvel phase 4
schedule right now the timing looks like
they'll drop Deadpool 3 after their
Fantastic Four reboot which right now
early prediction based on the way Kevin
Feige is talking about it might drop in
2023 at some point but just don't be
surprised if you see Deadpool popping up
doing Deadpool things in other people's
movies before he actually gets Deadpool
3 so everybody post all your Deadpool 3
theories in the comments below where do
you think the Deadpool is gonna show up
first
inside the MCU we got a whole bunch of
new stuff coming up I'll name a new
giveaway winner at the next time I post
a Marvel video everybody click here for
the brand new Rick and Morty's season 4
trailer and click here for my video on
the Joker movie ending scene thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]